[Music]
this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality and host of the ken coleman
show
where he talks about careers and finding
your purpose
your dream job is here to talk to you as
well so you got questions about money
you got questions about a career you got
questions about your life you jump in
the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five michael starts off this
hour in dayton ohio hey michael how are
you
hey dave how's it going it's an honor to
speak with you and ken
you too sir what's up hey
so i've been looking a lot at
cryptocurrency and
i know you guys are a little against it
the
it's pretty hostile in that environment
i have about 3 800 saved up from
working my job and i just want to know
what are the best investments to really
look at
and uh where to go about it
um hostile what do you mean hostile
well hostile where the validity of it
were the volatility
yes oh yeah definitely okay well i mean
you
you have to set your investment goals
with
what you believe is your best
path to becoming wealthy otherwise you
wouldn't do the investment right
and so um how old are you
i am 24. okay all right
so when i was 24 i made a lot of
mistakes buying
things that i thought would make me
wealthy quickly
and easily um i bought a lot of nothing
down real estate i went broke
as a result i i bought gold
futures once a buddy of mine had a
uh stockbroker ken a friend of his it
was a gold guy
and he had he had the ticket he had it
figured out he had the formula
and uh he had hit uh buying on the way a
future works when you purchase it at a
price
and if it goes under that if the if the
price is under that when you get to that
date
you get zero if you go if it's over that
then you get a multiple of what you put
in
and so um i bought a future put five
thousand dollars in that i didn't really
have
that's about all i had put the whole
five thousand dollars in because this
guy had hit
uh he had hit 14 times in a row on his
prediction
wow i mean he was amazing he was like a
gold savant he had it all figured out i
mean 14
times he had hit and the future made and
so the rate we went in at
i put five thousand dollars in and it
was a 10x if it hit i was gonna make 50
grand
it was this 15th try and we all know
where i'm going with this
oh yeah you can you can see where the
story's going you you know he missed on
that try and my
my my little bitty five thousand dollar
net worth was just evaporated
based on my attempt to make 50 000 in
90 days off of 5 000. um
and uh you know bitcoin's hot your
crypto's hot a lot of people making a
lot of money on it right now it is
as you said michael very very volatile
and so it falls for me an old guy
under the heading of getting rich quick
and i have not found many people that
get rich quick
and so i and i don't like losing money
i mean i just telling that story from 25
35 years ago makes my stomach yeah i
would think so
i i i work too hard for the money that
we get and that we get to keep after the
government takes their share
and so i don't like losing it so michael
you can certainly do what you want to do
but you called here
uh we do not tell people to invest in
highly volatile
uh unpredictable investments
and currencies of any kind fall in that
category
bitcoin would be the most volatile among
those
uh crypto would be the most volatile
among those
and statistically um you're going to
probably get your
uh you know you you might get it i mean
the game stop thing when the kids were
running the gamestop thing off of red
reddit
that was extraordinary and they made you
know one guy called here he put in 3 500
bucks and he made 50 grand
his hit i mean he was playing he was
running running short on that thing and
uh you know with those guys they were
they took him to task he took him the
woodshed it was interesting to watch
from the outside
but i've i've also got a friend that's
invested in six restaurants and
i i i go over there and eat
yeah i didn't invest in any of them
that's right and i like the people that
run them but i
you know you know what the failure rate
on restaurants is it's like almost all
of them favor yeah
yes you know they just don't make it and
so uh but he's in ve
he's an investor so he wants to do that
and that's fine i don't i
he called me said you won't put money in
this restaurant i'll go over and eat
i will invest in your food yes yeah
because well it's really true
the way you teach investing and the way
i live and the way you live that's right
and that's how you based it there is
risk involved of course
but when you're talking about bitcoin or
really volatile stocks like this
it is i think it's no different than
gambling i'm not trying to be cute with
the words
but there's investing which is i'm gonna
invest if you think about the way that
word is
then you talk about this kind of stuff
and it is a form of gambling it really
is
you're going all right i'm gonna put it
in and hope that it keeps going up but
this stuff could drop
just like this out of nowhere at a
minimum it's speculating
not investing that's what gambling might
be on one side and speculation yeah
that's a bit of a strong statement
investing
investing might be but that's what
investing investing
implies the tortoise yes speculating
implies the hair
yes that's right gambling is the uh
possum in the middle of the road okay
but yeah that's what it feels like
emotionally to me
it really does like if i were to invest
in bitcoin i'd be a i'd just be like
you got a better shot at bitcoin than
you do the lotto so that's all i'm
saying
that is fair but both of them are dumb
ideas in my mind
i and i and i didn't put any money in
either one of them
i've never bought a scratch off ticket
in my entire life dave you're no fun
no i just don't like giving my money
away i can drive
if i'm gonna have fun that way i'm gonna
roll down the window with 100 bills out
and call the traffic jam you know what
i'm going down the interstate
that's more fun yeah well you're too
competitive you want to have a shot at
making some money not just i'm i'm gonna
throw it in the air and to see what
happens
and you know of course everybody that's
a bitcoin genius right now thinks dave
ramsey's a out of touch boomer which is
probably true
but i'm also uh worth several hundred
million dollars so let's go figure that
out but um yeah i'd say look at the
scoreboard
take dave on all you want to but the
scoreboard is a scoreboard and it does
come down to
your risk tolerance what do you well not
just risk tolerance what is your goal
and what do the data points tell you so
i mean i've had people call this show
investing in beanie babies
really you remember when beanie babies
were crazy i was a kid i remember my
grandmother
people invested they were like they were
like such a hot commodity people were
investing in them
calling calling them as a collectible
calling in here saying i put my kids
college fund in beanie babies
i did that actually for me that's right
up there with bitcoin
yeah i mean you know i got a lot but i
did bob
the differences i did by beanie babies
as a gift [ __ ] no
sharon sharon got not not as an
investment but sharon
was collecting them as a hobby and now
okay that's good now the
grand babies and the shih tzu play with
them but they uh
that's all they're good for but you know
the thing is michael
you can invest in whatever you want but
the data points tell us that people who
do get rich quick don't
[Music]
that's the bottom line out of studying
10 000 millionaires the number of them
that got rich quick
is very very very small
the ones that were methodical and boring
and didn't have a good story to tell on
their golf course buddy
when they're playing golf it's a fishing
story with some stock that they got into
they didn't have any of that they just
were methodical and they were boring and
that's what i've done the second time
and the second time i kept it first time
i lost it all
do you do what you want to do this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today that means if you want to
talk careers your guy is here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five we're gonna talk about your
life and your money
lisa's in louisville kentucky hi lisa
welcome to the ramsey show
hi yes thank you um my question is
my husband and i recently but well we
don't have any debt except our first
mortgage which is 13
000 we got about a year and a half to
pay um but we just recently bought
um using our home equity loan uh some
land adjacent to our property
and it's 250 a month interest and so
my question and it's just interest only
right now
my question is if we have extra money
overtime stimulus money do we want to
put that toward the first mortgage or
should we be putting it toward the
bigger home equity
interest or not interest principle what
is your home equity loan balance
125 000 good lord
okay and what's your house worth
uh probably about 225
225 000. yeah and what's your household
income
oh um and think about that um
i think our gosh 75 000
possibly yeah i think so
okay this home equity loan is not going
to be paid off anytime soon and so it
scares me
home equity loans have uh variable
interest rates that are based on the
bank's
decision meaning they just get up every
morning they make up what they want to
charge
right now we have three percent yeah
right now um
and if they decide tomorrow it's four if
they decide the next day it's two
if they decide the next day it's six
it's up to them to decide it's not
indexed
to anything like an adjustable rate
mortgage is it's just up to the banks
freaking whim
the second thing they have is most of
them have a call provision
meaning if they look up and they don't
think that you're credit worthy anymore
they can call the entire loan this is a
very dangerous loan
so i would refinance and get one new
first mortgage
um maybe it's your credit union maybe
it's your same bank but not a heloc
uh heloc's are very dangerous if this
does not have a direct call provision or
a balloon i'll be shocked
almost all of them do and that means
they can just
they can just put you in foreclosure if
you can't pay them the whole thing
if they decide they like that i don't i
remember the balloon issue coming up and
i didn't think that was part of the deal
okay it may not be a direct balloon
there
may not be a set call but they have call
provisions in them
and they're very dangerous so i would
get rid of that mortgage but
you don't have the ability to pay it off
really fast unless you've got some cash
laying around you didn't tell me about
well we have some saving i mean we've
saved a lot
how much uh well
i don't really know off top of my head
i'd say
30 000 possibly in the bank
yeah uh that's not enough you don't have
enough money to pay this off
no no definitely not okay but i'm just
wondering what about we have a music
well we have some iras but we have a
mutual fund
that's 72 000 would it help at all to
take
25 000 out of that and put it toward the
principal
no i would put i would put everything i
could get my hands on that's not in a
retirement account
how old are you guys uh 50s
late 50s if you can scratch up the money
to pay it off pay it off
if not i mean completely pay it off
get rid of it i would pay it off but
other than that i would go to your
credit union and get a
fixed rate 10-year mortgage
no closing costs no points fixed
rate fully amortizing no balloons
no calls 10 year mortgage and pay this
thing off
that's what i would do in this because
i'm worried about what's going to happen
to you here i in 30 years of coaching
i've seen people come into my office and
they
you know somebody loses a job and the
bank deems you not credit worthy and
they
exercise one of the call options and
these things and you just can get
screwed
um and it it doesn't happen often but it
happens often enough that it scares me
for you
so i would get it refinanced and or i
would scrape together 125 000
out of the corners of the couch and get
it paid off without
cashing out retirement
so um yeah yeah i
it's just i mean right now with race
where they are if they can do that
refinance then really start knocking
this thing down
that's that's the way to go stephanie's
with us in
tampa florida hi stephanie welcome to
the ramsay show
thank you dave hi ken how are you guys
doing great how can we help
um well um i i'll just get right to it
um
i am about 45
000 in debt um
some of that is owned to the irs um
some of it is in collections most of it
to the student loan
and then the other half is through
credit cards
um with two of them being with a credit
i think consolidation company so
clearly i'm overwhelmed because
i am self-employed i work from home
but my income per month is around 700
maybe a little bit more if i'm lucky so
um i do
have a thousand dollars put aside i did
read your book
a few months ago and that's done thanks
to a car
that i that i had sold um and
but with the money i make now i'm just
like
wondering like stephanie you're starving
to death
700 a month you're living way below the
poverty level
yes but there is a reason for that i i
do live with my parents
um i i love living with my
fiance how old are you before
i mean why don't you get a job
i'm actually doing that right now i
actually have an interview later this
afternoon
um which i hope if everything goes wrong
i'll get it and i'll be
making double than what i am now with
more hours
she'll be waking more than that fourteen
hundred
no no no no it would be like right now
my hours aren't that much
um it's i would say maybe
it would it's like 20 hours a week
stephanie what are you applying to do
and what is it that you really want to
do answer those two questions
so what i'm trying to do is
it's a i guess an administrative
assistant
um it's uh like a scheduler um
which would make about 20
okay um with uh full-time hours okay um
what i wanted to do and the reason why
i'm actually living with my parents
now is that i was actually supposed to
move to japan for a teaching job
teaching your phone's cutting in and out
can you speak directly into your phone
please
yes is this better yes ma'am um yeah so
um where where did i leave off that you
couldn't hear me what you really want to
do what's it what's the big goal for you
professionally what do you want to do
so um i really want to teach and
um i actually was supposed to go to
japan
uh to do that job um my fiance is
already there
um but thanks to the pandemic i
i wasn't able to go before the borders
closed but you're qualified to teach
here in the us presumably
um the my degree isn't in teaching it's
something that i found out after i
graduated that i wanted to do
so right now i i wouldn't have the
qualifications for each year okay well
you got to get yourself stable
financially and you're living with your
parents so
obviously that allows you to keep your
expenses low but you got to work the
debt snowball you just read dave's book
uh you got your thousand dollars and now
this is about getting hired and this is
two and three jobs i mean you're young
enough
uh you're not married this is no life at
all you're working
like absolute like a maniac and then
you're knocking this stuff out you can
actually do this
but you're gonna have to go at it like
you've never gone at anything in your
life
and as you're doing that you're going to
get stable and you can
take the steps necessary to be a teacher
whether it's back in japan when that
opens up which i think will be sooner
rather than later
but but you got to get real serious
right now you got a good situation with
the parents
so now it's work work work work work pay
the debt off
yeah you 20 hours a week isn't your
answer 80 hours a week
is your answer and minimum wage is not
your answer um
so yeah go the ken coleman website
kingcoleman.com
or solutions.com ken coleman
and get a bunch of cans downloadable for
free tools
on getting hired and getting into a
different role uh you need to go make
some money kiddo
uh you you're you're living on nothing
you're starving to death
you have an income crisis
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and 6 gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 a month
by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save
50 off your first month pure talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at
jeff's in 825-5225 idaho hi jeff how can
we help
good afternoon first of all i just want
to say thanks to ken
i love his show glad he's a part of what
you guys do i've got a lot of great
tips and advice from him over the time
so thank you thank you jeff appreciate
that
my question for you today dave i
recently found out i work for a great
company it's an esop company
but i just discovered they're not
matching my 401k which is fine
the esop more than except for it but
should i be investing differently
um i'm 56 and i would like to retire
by the time i'm 65 to 67 i'm flexible
with that but
according using your calculator i have
about 1.3
by the time we retire we currently have
404
in our in our retirement i'd like to get
that number
double about that should i be investing
differently than my 401k
well the first thing we try to do is get
a match the esop gives you a
payment whether you get a match or not
whether you put anything in or not
correct
that is correct so your first thing is
get a match you don't have a match are
you married does your wife have a match
uh she she does she works for
um the university here and they they
match
i think they do okay we're gonna look
into everything the best thing you can
do
is to make 100 return on your money
that's a match
right that's kind of a no-brainer
regardless of the taxation issue
the the best thing you can do is do an
uh a match
with a roth actually so if she has a
roth or you have a roth 401k or she has
a roth 401k or 403b
with a match we'll do the match first
we're going to 15 of your income till
your house is paid off if you're in baby
step four you know that right
which we are okay so using the 15
we do rock paper scissors except only
one direction and so it's
matches first beats roth by itself
beats traditional so does your 401k have
a roth
no and neither does hers okay then we're
gonna do her match
first we're gonna do two individual
roths with a smartvestor pro next
and you can do 7000 each because you're
over 50 right
i am she's not she's uh 13 years younger
than us okay so
then we can do you would still get there
do six and seven thousand there
and uh that's 13. if those two numbers
her match plus those two roths does not
get you to 15
then i would go to either hers
or your traditional 401 case
whichever one has the best mutual fund
options in it the best performing mutual
fund options in it
the four types of mutual funds we talk
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international
so if we look at say uh you're 401k and
they're like
they're decent and we look at hers and
they're like those are really good funds
then we're going to go with hers with
the match and hers after the roth
with the third step back to traditional
401k but if yours has got better return
than hers
then we'll just do hers match individual
roths over here
and then bounce back to yours to finish
up to 15 because you got
good options in there okay
match beats roth beats traditional
okay awesome now we're always looking
for those types of mutual funds those
four types
with long long track records and
that is the number one key we found in
the millionaire study to becoming
wealthy is that
track record right there that path that
clear path
megan's in owensboro kentucky hi megan
welcome
to the ramsay show hi dave how are you
better than i deserve what's up in your
world
okay so my husband and i um
we just sold our current home and we
have met
with some builders and we are
we have plans to build a home but i've
recently started channeling in
with you and listening to all of your
advice and all about the baby steps
we have well over 20 percent down but we
still have some vehicle debt
how much do you own your vehicles why
would you
45 000 holy crap
what are you driving um
well that's kind of another story but my
husband um had a rough year last year
and he actually bought two different
vehicles without telling me
um a toyota so this is the way he this
is the way he medicates he goes and buys
cars
yeah it seems that way ouch
spit just spends money in general um
cars
and clothes and just
different different things yeah
okay uh so if we
get on a good track and get rid of the
vehicle debt unless we fix that
you're going to be right back into a
mess aren't you
yeah so i think we start with him
does he does he want to work does he
want to work a system to build wealth or
does he want to continue to be a
freaking child
he he's all he says he's on board with
this
um plan that i want you know basically
your plan
good sell the trucks and i know you say
not to modify
no just sell the trucks sell the cars
yeah let's see if he's on plan he's not
on plan
i don't believe you no and you don't
believe you
no not really yeah i'm sorry baby girl
yeah you guys got to work through that
stuff because that's that's
the these trucks and financial problems
are the symptom
they're not the problem so
ken if they dig in and get on the same
page really
then it what's your household income by
the way
um about 115. okay
and which which two vehicles do we buy
what are they
um a brand new toyota tacoma and a
vintage
like 1960s mustang okay
how old is your husband we uh we're both
31.
okay um and we have about
80 000 right now saved without
you know for the for the potential you
guys can decide what you want to do
you're both um
walking around in 30 year old bodies and
so it's legal for you to do whatever you
want to do
as far as these issues go what would i
tell you to do if you were my kid and my
kid is your age
okay my my grown kids watch her show too
yeah the ramsey rachel's 33 okay so
what would i tell you all to do if
winston and rachel sat down in front of
me with this
[Music]
i'm going to tell you what i have done
to myself
in these situations i would sell the
vehicles
not because it's necessary but because
you need to prove to yourself and he
needs to prove to himself
that we're going to start being
grown-ups and both of these cars were
impulse medicaid
medicated purchases is what you
described he was medicating having a bad
year
in air quotes um and um
uh uh you know you need to break i i
went and if i can do something and pull
it off
and it makes my dumb decision earlier
go away then it makes me more likely to
go back to the dumb decision versus if i
amputate these vehicles i have to
feel it then and let me tell you i'm a
car guy
and getting rid of a vintage 60s mustang
makes my stomach hurt right now just
telling you to do that because i
wouldn't be able to do it
i mean i could do it but that just makes
my that's i'm hurting i'm hurting yeah
cringing ken's got a great karman ghia
he's redoing right now
i love classic cars yeah look i i just
want to say this
you gotta break the cycle of this and
the spirit of this is more important
than the actual math
yeah and after the discipline he's gonna
have to get a vision you two are gonna
have to come together this is a marriage
thing and you guys at 31 have got to get
a vision what do we want for our lives
that isn't just stuff he's going after
stuff we've all done
stuff before to to make things feel
better but what's the big vision and
it'll help him with this
as dave says kari amputation if he's got
uh
a big vision that you two hopefully on
the same page for what do we want for
our lives
what does it look like 20 years from now
this is a big decision
and and to the best of your ability i'd
get with a counselor is what i think i
think this is a
we need to get on the same page about
this money thing
because it's coming out of another place
that's going to get us in big trouble
so either you put 40 000 down on your
house and you keep these cars
paid pay them off or you sell them and
you put 80 000
on the house and you have
proven that you're moving in a different
direction emotionally
and spiritually away from this stuff
addiction
that's what i would want to do if i were
looking in his mirror and i was him
that's called manhood baby this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
ken coleman of the ken coleman show is
my host today my co-host today
folks there's a ton of underrated
holidays and this is one of my favorite
may 2nd is national life insurance day
you've got to be kidding me it may not
sound like much fun
well it's because it isn't
i'm going to just get me a confetti
cannon yeah
[Laughter]
but as silly as that sounds life
insurance isn't silly at all it protects
your family
when you pass away so they're not
dealing with money stress on top
of losing you and you need the right
kind of life insurance and of course the
only thing we recommend at ramsey
solutions is term life insurance
10 to 12 times your income on you in 15
to 20 year
level term our free coverage checkup
tool will help you find the right term
life policy
plus other types of insurance you do and
don't need to protect you and your
family
to get the results it's free text
checkup two
three three seven eight nine text
checkup it's free
don't don't put in it's free it is free
but text checkup
233 789
candace is with us in sacramento hi
candace welcome to the ramsey show
hi guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so i'm having a bit of a moral dilemma
that i'd love your advice on
um my son he's 19 years old
and um we have decided as a family
including him in the decision-making
process
that you know he's got to be out on his
own on june 1st
um we are a month away and he has no
money saved
um and his plan is to go live on a
friend's couch
in the bad part of town where the
two-bedroom apartment that has five
people already living in it
so my husband and i are debating do we
give him more time
um he's shown no motivation to do
anything more
than to save um so we're just trying to
figure out
what to do and he's our first teenager
so we need some help
wow that's some hard discussions isn't
it
yeah yeah it is you know what we
he's a very unmotivated teenager um
just works with the drive-in making 1200
bucks a month
you know he could probably pay to run an
apartment with some friends but he's
done
nothing to save he's making dumb stupid
kid decisions
um so we feel like maybe he won't go do
anything
if we don't kick him out uh so yeah what
what are your thoughts
hmm
[Music]
coleman what would your dad have done oh
well i i feel like there needs to be
some
some details here on the back story it
sounds like there's been some behavior
that's violating some
values and some house rules that are
just at this point you and your husband
are saying this is non-negotiable and i
guess he's admitted to this and that's
where we got to the agreement
of june one is that a quick okay well my
dad
my dad would have held to the june one
despite the fact that i would have been
woefully
uh in this scenario if this is me and
i'm not prepared he would have held to
it
and i i got to tell you i've got
teenagers myself
and i'm trying to put myself into this
situation candace but i think that
failure in my life has been the greatest
teacher and there's all different types
of failure here
and it's really hard as a parent uh i
don't have it figured out
and uh so the situation i hold to it you
and his dad and him are in the
discussion right
yes uh-huh yeah and we've been we we
decided this back in february
after he got fired from like his third
you know little minimum wage job
um and we were like come on dude you
gotta you gotta start doing something
and he was just you know
partying a lot uh coming home at all
hours he doesn't you know and
he was paying rent to us then and so i
was doing what you know ao has
had his dad do back in the day which was
you know he'd pay us rent and we'd save
it and then one day when he moved out we
were going to give it to him
but then he got a speeding ticket so you
know we were like well luckily we had
this money saved for you
uh we he he hears you in my office
every day all day so he knows the baby
steps
but there's you know there's nothing to
get his life together
so well um
you know i'm going to take a page out of
dr john's book
that i might not have a year ago um
and i'm probably going to write all of
this down
as a letter for him to have okay
and physically carry with him and the
letter also
includes not only the things that he's
not done
but it includes the fact that any
time that you want some help
anytime that you're ready to move
in the direction that are consistent
with the values that we've taught you
we will help you do that we are not
carving you out of our life as a matter
of fact we are heartbroken
i mean my heart's broken just listening
and i can't imagine anything harder and
sadder
um but uh
you you know that you run the danger if
you go the other direction of being an
enabler
and he'll be 29 and still doing the same
thing
right that's what we're afraid of yeah
because there's no progression and no
pain to move him off a dead center so
um it might be that that that's what his
wake-up call is and you've heard a oh
story his dad kicked him out he lived in
his car
yeah because he was he was a smart ankle
and smart off at his mother
and uh you know run up a bunch of debt
and got kicked out of school and they
threw him out and he lived in his car
for a year
but his dad checked with him every week
and made sure he was okay but let him
live in his car
you know and so and yeah you know tell
you that's the best thing ever happened
to him
um when he and but when he did say all
right dad i'm ready to straighten up and
come home first thing he handed him was
a dave ramsey budget and he got on it by
god then
you know because he was because his
little his little tail was ready but
that's a o's story uh in a nutshell and
so i'm thinking
the thing you don't want to do with this
is just abandon him
to himself i still want to keep i still
want to keep as much love
and influence over him as i possibly can
by constantly extending
not help that enables
not help that causes him to continue on
the same path but any
sign that's positive i'm going to meet
him on that sign
and you know he goes and gets a job dad
i want to try and get out of that good
if you
start working on your debts i'll pay
some of it i'll pay you know
i'll match whatever you put on your dad
or uh mom i'm gonna start doing a budget
and
okay come over here and sit down i will
have dinner and i'll show you and i'll
coach you with this and i'll meet with
you
over coffee once a week and you're not
abandoning him
that's my point okay and that yeah
that would make this the only way it's
tolerable for me emotionally
it's real hard yeah candace i i like
dave's idea of the letter i would add
a section in there on what you and your
husband have noticed about him his
brightest moments in life whether been
on the sporting field
or in the classroom or at a science fair
this is when you're your best
yeah and this is what we see and you've
got all this potential this teacher
said in the sixth grade about you i
would remind him of his tremendous
value and i would also say hey we
believe there's a unique role that you
were put on this planet to fill
and we will help you get there uh but
this is an agreement and you know
whatever if you want to put in there but
i would i would show a lot of value
there and let him see that
uh and then i think i love dave's point
on checking in when he wakes up in his
own vomit after partnering and partying
all night that letter's laying there
that's right and he remembers the value
he remembers his value
i'm just curious real quick has he ever
shared a dream with you
for his future um
yeah he has a well i don't know if i
necessarily a hundred percent align with
it
but i didn't ask you that what'd he say
yeah
his dream um is he wants to go into
business
um in the dispensary business because in
california you know marijuana is legal
um so but he likes the medicinal
purposes of it and so he wants to go
into that
world but you have to be 21. so for him
he just wants a way to get free pot that
has nothing to do with it
exactly you know i've been encouraging
him to
um you know he you know he got offered a
job to work
um as like an activity director for you
know uh
old um older elderly people home yeah
are you guys
are you guys in a good church candace
are y'all in a good church
yeah i am my son hate or miss on if he
goes
no your husband too my husband does not
go
no i think you all ought to get some
people in your corner that are walking
this out with you
because you're going to have idiots say
this is tough love and it's not tough
love it's just love
[Music]
tough love is no different than love
love has boundaries to it
and as for me and my house we don't do
things this way
and so you can't live here if you're
gonna do this this way that's what
you're saying
and because you love him but be there
for him don't abandon him in this
process
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i am dave
ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality and host of the ken coleman
show
is my co-host today as we take your
calls about your life
and about your money open phones here at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five james is in nashville
to start off at this hour hi james how
are you
pretty good dave how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
so my wife and i actually got married
back here in october actually in
nashville right on the water
under the pedestrian bridge but that
obviously equals joint finances now so
my wife went to
occupational therapy school and she's a
pretty big
student loan from that so her student
loans are around 177
000 obviously with uh the bonded plan
right now there's no interest accruing
they're public loans until september 30
as of now um at that time so before
september 30th
we would have the ability to pay them
off in lump sum so just pay them off in
cash
so i'm just wondering if that's the best
thing for us to do we would be able to
build up a
emergency fund pretty quickly so we'd be
okay
but it's a lot of our non-qualified
assets going towards the
student loans so just looking for your
perspective around this
wow well congratulations on the marriage
um where did all these assets come from
where'd this money come from
uh pretty fortunate pretty blessed i
work in the financial industry
um i have a pretty decent income and
i've been investing since i was about 16
years old
um so just over time able to build them
up and we also have a decent amount
and our qualified retirement assets now
we're all 401
and a roth ira as well how old are you
guys
i am 27 my wife just turned 26. wow
and what's your household income
household would probably be for this
year uh let's just call it 300
conservatively 300
you guys are killing it that's what i
smelled good i'm so proud of y'all
well done appreciate that fabulous
fabulous income
okay so let's kind of play these two
things out
one is you wait till september and then
you pay it off
two is you pay it off today correct
correct yep okay and so the difference
is what you would earn on the money
between now and september
correct exactly opportunity cost of
capital exactly
exactly i got the same degree you do and
so um
the uh
i mean we're talking about uh depending
on how it's invested
uh what six months and so
uh six eight thousand bucks
right okay right all right so all of the
data that we have
on building wealth is
based the people that have built wealth
have followed a set of principles
steady and they haven't found
shortcuts and the thing that
the way you and i are trained
academically our mind leads us to
um my wife calls it scheming and
scamming we're always trying to figure
out
an angle because we know so much math
it's it's the curse of the math nerd we
know so much math so we have an
advantage but we know so much math we
can get caught up in the analysis
and almost get paralysis of the analysis
instead of just going forward and
driving the car correctly does that make
any sense to you right
it does make sense it does make sense
and i should have expanded on the
question too because we're looking at
opportunity cost of capital now but
we're in this weird time where there's
no interest accruing i know
on these public loans given kovid i know
but the rate is high
so it's eight percent when it does turn
back on so so you would pay it off
it's like it's like let me it's like a
uh someone that makes
fifty thousand dollars a year has a uh a
ten thousand dollar furniture bill 90
days same as cash
do we wait 90 days and play this play
the float
or do we just pay it off
or or and i'm sorry from the spoke do we
refinance which is probably a big no
yeah it would be a big problem we're not
keeping it because again there's no data
that says i got rich because i kept
refinancing my student loan debt
does that there's just no one has ever
done that in the history of mankind
it runs around in our math brains
because our math brings
but so here's what i here's what i end
up doing if i run the numbers down like
we just did
and all of my gyrations make eight
thousand dollars and you make 300 a year
that's telling me that i'm i'm working
too hard at this situation
and i need to just go with the smart
common sense principle
because the actual math doesn't mount to
squat
if it amounted uh right if if you made
fifty thousand dollars a year and it
amounted to fifty thousand then we'd
have to talk about well do we screw
around with this a little bit you know
but this is eight thousand dollars which
honestly you could have made that while
we were talking about it
right right i guess it's a psychological
factor exactly
i built up this non-qualified message
exactly and i can pay off these loans
but then a lot of that you're gonna pay
them off
it goes away every bit of intellect
tells you you've got to pay them off by
by the day that first interest is due so
our only real discussion is now to
september
you know that part you've already made
that decision and you're
you can argue yourself down off that
ledge i don't have to do that
so you can do whatever you want to do i
have had
a good benefit of breaking my math nerd
self over into grandma's common sense
and going
i'm getting this crap out of my life
while i can i got this beautiful woman
and when i look at her i don't want to
see student loans
that's exactly right and they make so
much money as he said in his own words
we can build up that emergency fund so
quickly
but dave this is where we get to the
politicalization of psychology you know
where we say oh well they might pay them
off they might forgive them
they might care there's no program where
they're giving it well
not not any that have been proposed yet
not yet but for 177
000 for people to make 300 right they've
only been for up to 50 for people who
don't make money that's right but the
politician
you're an evil rich person making 300
you're screwed by the democrats oh yeah
so it's just it's just better to get it
out of the way and not hope that
something happens you know just
just get it out of the way knock it out
and i get it it's a straight psychology
play
yeah because he's made good money he's
been really smart it's also painful
cutting a check for 177 000
too well it's like i have a zero percent
interest loan on my car
you know i don't but i'm saying people
call that question why would i pay that
off
because it's not going to be zero
percent when you're done if you keep
screwing around with this you're gonna
end up getting hammered
one way or another with these people and
oh by the way it's not zero percent
because the only reason you get zero
percent in the car lot
is if you pay full sticker price and
only idiots do that
you never pay full sticker price for a
car ever
unless you're trying to get a zero
percent loan so by translation it's not
zero percent because you paid a premium
for the car
back that out of your interest rate
that's just how things work in the real
world y'all
okay so you know it's like
you know i think if i could just
refinance my credit cards and get them
from 18
down to 14 i could really i'd be able to
break through this thing
sure 4 on 10 000 is 400 bucks you can't
buy a biscuit dude
for the amount of math gyration you're
screwing around with here
it's just and that's if you back it down
into real nominal dollars folks
when you're looking at these things like
we did with him like james because james
is
a very smart guy obviously and dumb
people don't make 300 usually
and so usually but uh uh
but yeah i mean he's if and if you're
careful you get in your own way
you step on yourself so i pay it off is
what i do
today by close of business i'd be
debt-free
that's what i would do if i woke up in
your shoes this is the ramsay show
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five our question today comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure or you pick the wrong
color i've done these things
they'll remake your window blinds for
free this is a great company you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more blinds.com use the
promo code
ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from sam in texas
i'm a school teacher and my wife and i
are on baby step two i'm very
dissatisfied with my teaching
environment
and i'm looking to get out of the
profession i feel called
to go into ministry but i am not willing
to go into more debt
to pay for it which is more important
paying off debt
or getting out of a toxic environment
well sam that's a
false choice you can get out of debt and
get out of baby step two and keep
walking the baby steps
and also get out of a toxic environment
but the way you do it
is the key so i think sometimes when
people feel
as though they are in a toxic
environment and toxic environment is one
of those
general terms here we have to look at am
i in an abusive situation
where i am emotionally very very
unhealthy and unstable
or physically outside of that it's one
of those situations when when you are in
debt and you were walking out the baby
steps
we have to change that mindset sometimes
and say okay until
i can get out of this toxic
teaching environment into a better
teaching environment
or into a day job that will allow me to
get out of debt
and then save up the money for any
qualification necessary to move into
ministry
then i'm gonna put up with it and so
it's not an either or
continue to pay off debt do not
and for any reason put off the baby
steps because you're not happy in your
work
what we want to look at is why am i
unhappy and i have many teachers dave
that'll call the ken coleman show and
when i dig into it we find that
it's not necessarily the teaching it's
the particular environment so if we can
get in a healthier environment
great but until you're able to get
qualified for ministry
um you've got to work the day job you've
got to work the baby steps
and then the ministry is still going to
be there the ability to get qualified to
do ministry
will still be there and even though your
heart longs to get there
there are times where we do what we have
to do to be able to do what we want to
do later it's not an either or
i'd be willing to bet that part of sam's
calling
to ministry is teaching i absolutely
agree he's going to teach in a church
environment or
a ministry he's not he's not burned out
on teaching
he's just looking for a different way to
be a teacher the paperwork the
bureaucracy
the lack of a control in the classroom i
hear this helicopter parents
oh cray-cray parents you're driving
teachers out of the classroom
because you're bozos wacky curriculums
and other
lack of discipline in the schools
dad gum inmates are running the asylum
that's
right i think that teachers want to
leave i don't blame you i don't blame
you in those situations
i get it um so
here's what you do uh the emotion has
built up you can read it between the
lines it's seeping
in here the word choice the uh the the
the word order everything in this says
i'm
i'm really over this yeah ready to walk
yeah
and you got you got to hold back on that
and say i'm going to do this in a wise
and mature way unless you have some kind
of
an ethical situation that you're calling
toxic
um i i i will wager to say
what you have is a highly unpleasant
environment i'm not sure toxic is is not
it's an overused word these days
everything's toxic to something somebody
doesn't like it anymore right i don't
like it that bubblegum is toxic you know
i don't like this
i don't like anything it's toxic it's
toxic and that's the second time you and
i've heard in two weeks toxic work
environment
when i question whether the actual is
really toxic rather than
just highly unpleasant that's right well
he says right here i'm very dissatisfied
with my teaching environment
yeah and you know and then it's toxic
later but the teacher i mean
i mean your boss is a jerk that i don't
know if you call that fact i don't know
if i call that toxic
no it's not it's it's undesirable yes
and
am i gonna quit that gum right yeah
eventually as soon as i can find a place
to go that's right we want to step into
something else
so it might be a two-step procedure you
might step into a different different
teaching role so you can finish up
getting out of debt and
work on your ministries creds uh
whatever credentials are required in
your particular denomination some
denominations don't have required
credentials you just have to declare
yourself i are a preacher
and then you are one you know and that's
uh
other denominations are very strict
about a doctorate and other things in
theology
obviously training is never a bad thing
theology included but
it is not a it is not table stakes nope
unless you've chosen a particular
denomination that says it is that's
correct i know i've got friends of mine
that went into ministry dave
they went into a non-pastoral where they
they didn't need to be
uh they didn't have to have the the
certain you know them div or whatever
would be for preaching and ordained and
all that but they got in and they were
on a church staff and then the church
actually paid for some of their
education
churches will do that and it's not a
guarantee it's not something you walk
around asking for but
there are ways to get there and i think
what happens when someone is really
unhappy you start this
is the case where you use the proximity
principle too
you go ahead and start being a
irreplaceable lay
person at a local congregation to the
point they hire you
that's right hey i'll start teaching a
new class i'll i'll i'll teach two new
classes i know
four different church administrators uh
that are uh in
in the administration side uh
of ministry that came out of corporate
america and the first thing they did
before they became full-time staff
members was
they were virtually full-time lay
volunteers
handling all this stuff in the church
because we can't do without these guys
and then they go look i'm going to tell
you know target or whoever bye-bye i'm
not going to work for them anymore i'm
going to i'm going to go work for the
church
and uh so they made a transition that
way by getting in proximity
that's exactly right and that's how we
build that bridge to where we move the
undesirable work environment
and we replace it and by the way we
never miss a paycheck
we never miss a debt snowball payment
that's how you do it but there are
sometimes it's the stress i don't think
i can do it anymore yes you can
it may be you need to fix it it's easier
to do it if you can see
the end of the tunnel no question i'm
going to take these three steps and then
i'll be out of here versus i feel
trapped here
that's exactly trapped here adds stress
that's right and in this situation he's
going i've got to go to school to get
into ministry no
not necessarily not to necessarily get
in and make those connections then that
additional schooling well we're going to
do that when we can cash flow it
yeah good stuff linda's in anaheim
california hi linda welcome to the
ramsey show
hello mr ramsey thank you so much for
taking my call it is a true honor to
speak with you today
i am uh i am happy to report i am an
everyday millionaire effect of march of
this year
way to go very happy to yeah to share
that with you i'm six
payments away from finishing off the
mortgage and it's a
true blessing wow yes thank you thank
you um
the reason why i'm calling is i need
some advice um i am
soon parting ways with an ex soon to the
business part
x business partner and we have an llc
we have an investment property in a
different state
that she that i propose to sell she
wishes to
buy me out so my question is what is
this fair
i i i want to be you know first and
foremost fair what is the
how do i calculate my share of this
do you know is is it the appraised value
minus the loan divided by
two or is it you wouldn't net that no
you would be the appraised value minus
about 15
for expenses if you sold it through a
real estate agent you'd have closing
costs and other things
and so i would take 85 percent of
appraisal minus the loan divided by two
okay that's what i figured i wanted to
be fair on that
that's very fair well that that because
that's about all you would need but by
the way
15 might be a little rich on expenses
but you're also not going to get
asking price usually in this market you
might get more than asking price
depending on what it is but
uh most real estate deals don't sell for
asking price
over the scope of your life so um
like i've got that actually in our uh
estate plan
if one of our kids wants to buy we got a
bunch of real estate when the kids wants
to buy one of the other ones out
and they want to sell out they need to
do it at 85 percent of appraisal
because that covers all the expenses and
what if you know if we turned it into
money
that's all it would be by the time you
negotiate down
and you and you pay some expenses to
sell it that's all the net money is
going to be there
so that's the calculation i use this is
the ramsey shop
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage david and pam are with
us
hey guys how are you hey dave hey
welcome welcome where do you guys live
uh pennsylvania all right cool what part
of pennsylvania uh wellsville
pennsylvania all right what's that near
uh south of harrisburg harrisburg area
okay cool well welcome to nashville
good to have you and all the way down
here to do a debt free screen how much
have you paid off
we've paid off 178 000
in 22 months good for you guys well done
and your range of income during that
time uh we started at 220 000 and ended
at 229
000. wow what do y'all do for a living
i'm an executive director at a long-term
care facility
and i'm a nurse practitioner awesome two
great careers well done
what kind of debt was this hundred and
seventy eight thousand dollars
paid off the house oh look at the weird
people
awesomeness how old are you guys uh i'm
55.
uh-huh i'll soon be 54. there you go
good very good at a paid-for house right
what's the house worth uh 380 to 400.
wow
how fun is that it's great when did you
pay it off what day uh april 9th so
actually today would be the first day we
didn't have to write a mortgage check so
how's it feel great awesome i think it's
still sort of
settling in you know it's a little
surreal isn't it yes wow very cool
well congratulations so you decided to
get after that mortgage two years ago
what got you guys on fire well i think
it started
when uh we were at church and they were
advertising for uh
uh financial piece they were gonna teach
and i never heard of the program before
i never heard of your name and i asked
pam i said well
you know what's dave ramsey what's
what's this program about she says i
think it's something to do with
budgeting
we thought we don't have a problem with
budgeting we pay our bills on time sure
so we didn't think much of it we didn't
sign up for the course
and six days later i was at work having
lunch with some colleagues
and uh someone at the table she said
that you know she's a nurse at
necessities her husband's a surgeon she
said
you know we make really good money but
we're broke so i've been reading this
book
the total money makeover by dave ramsey
i thought well that's my sign if i heard
your name in
in twice in a seven day period so i went
home and
looked up the baby steps read through
those and to me it made sense and i
was telling pam at the time and we
watched some debt-free screens we
watched some of the uh
podcasts and uh i tell you just really
it's like we need to do this i'm not
sure why we weren't uh
doing this you know a lot of decades ago
yes yeah
well you make great money and so yeah
but you weren't broke
broke i mean you weren't not like your
friend but but you uh
but you did say i can knock off the
house this is doable yes yeah
it's kind of that light bulb moment a
little bit did you end up going through
financial peace after all uh we did it
later just online with our
with ourselves we were actually on uh
baby step three
when we first found out about you and so
immediately got on that
we uh got set up with a budget and
started actually um
i guess you had mentioned you know you
get a raise when you actually start you
know getting rid of things you don't
really need in your budget
we uh got rid of directv and we took
that money and put it towards the house
uh i had a whole life insurance policy
we got rid of that
we got rid of the credit cards and i met
up with a smart investor
uh pro scott rob out of york pa who uh i
had a uh
403 b hold everything yeah and um
you know initially we thought you know i
looked at the numbers it's like you know
i think we could pay this off in three
years
and you mentioned it in your show before
where you'll say something like you know
i think you'll pay you know
24 months but i think if you really get
on fire you can do it less than that
and we just started putting everything
into it um
and the pandemic helped it somewhat
because we didn't eat out for like a
year
yeah and we took all that extra money
and yes
we pretty much
[Laughter]
so that's uh we just put everything
towards the house wow
wow did you work extra hours did you
guys double down there or just just
really tighten everything
she worked a lot extra hours but she
salaried so
with the pandemic and health care at all
right of course both that both of you
had i mean nursing home wow what a
stressful year and then you know and
there's nurse practitioners well i mean
stressful year you just say practitioner
yes yeah okay yeah so both of you were
in the
i mean you're on the firing lines for
sure wow and still
just said okay we're knocking this out i
like it
so good you guys well done your rock
stars man
such heroes i'm so proud of you well
done well done
so what advice do you have
to that 52 year old dink professional
couple out there double income no kids
there's no kids at home anyway
um and they just need to lean in and do
it
i mean i mean what what what what is the
steps what are the main things to get
out of debt
i think work as a team you have to be a
team you have to set a goal
and just write a plan and go for it
yeah and i think um one of the things
that
just through the years you know it's
like how much do you invest you know am
i going to be ready for retirement
and it kind of gave us that reassurance
when we actually
finally linked up with a smart investor
pro to look at where we're at
what we need to do to you know for our
plans for retirement um
you know how to switch things from
traditional ira or to raw doing all
those things to kind of
now to plan for the future
every little thing yeah yeah yeah and
with no payments at all
i mean and a decade out at least until
retirement it's your choice of course
but
um i mean you're going to be
multi-millionaires that's so cool
because i mean this great income and not
a payment in the world
i love it well done well done well done
so who are your biggest cheerleaders uh
one another for sure and uh our
daughters we have two granddaughters
and there's uh our son-in-laws and we
have
seven wonderful grandchildren hey there
they are
and that was part of our why not just uh
paying everything off but you know that
we could uh increase our giving increase
our investing and
uh those sorts of things but also you
know what can we do we talked about
all the time you know we want to help
out with the grandkids um
schooling and things like that so now
we're in a position where we can
uh do those things yeah yeah you just
write a check it's not a thing
i feel so good i'm so proud of you guys
well done well done excellent excellent
stuff yeah you know i'm hearing a little
bit of legacy
i'm hearing that obviously for the
grandkids everybody gets that but i'm
just curious
giving outside of the family do you guys
have been able to have those dream
conversations and some things of
fingerprints you guys can leave behind
but not yet um you know this is our
first month we actually have
the extra income so to speak you know
because there's not a mortgage
um other than tithing uh which is what
we do now give to missions
it's true uh but other than that we
haven't really uh
come up with what we want to do what's
the first big thing you're going to buy
to celebrate
probably a car for her she has 300 000
miles and uh had to go to autozone this
morning get some parts to get us back to
pa
yeah you need to buy her a car you need
to buy the woman a car
as soon as you get back just write a
check and get her get a nice car
dad i love it well done you guys if you
live like no one else later you get to
live and give like no one else i'm so
proud of you guys
all right it's david and pam from
harrisburg pennsylvania area 178
000 paid off 22 months making 220-229
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one we're dead
i love it man that is awesomeness right
there
how powerful powerful i mean david's
showing off a little voice there he went
up a couple octaves he
showed some real baritone there i don't
know if he sings a church or not but
that was pretty that was better than a
screen
man way to go well just so fun to see
that isn't it they're just so light and
so exciting to see what they're going to
be able to do as a couple they've got so
much legacy to build
so fun yeah and here's the thing maybe
you don't pay off your house in
22 months maybe you do it in
eight years because maybe you don't make
220 000
but your house will still be paid off
when you do that yeah
and so you can still take from this
debt-free scream that sense of
freedom and peace that you felt on them
you're right it's a sense of their light
they seem light don't they yes very much
versus heavy
yeah there's no dark cloud today is the
first day without the payment
no house that's crazy fun payment
no house payment what if you did that
why don't you do that i think you
should do that no
house payment
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five when it comes to making big money
or life moves
like buying a home or getting married or
having a baby it's likely the last thing
on your mind to think about
insurance but you need the right
insurance coverage
i know big changes are overwhelming but
what could be even
more overwhelming is finding yourself in
a situation where you and your family
are in the hole because you did not have
the right coverage
now if not taking the time or not having
the time or energy
is what's keeping you from getting the
right insurance coverage one of our
endorsed local providers or elp
insurance agents can help they're
independent agents they shop among a
gazillion companies and get you
the best coverage at the best price
and there's no charge for that the
insurance company pays them once you
select which one you want to go with but
they work for you
that's right an independent agent shops
a variety of insurance options finds you
the best explains all the technical
lingo
for free all you have to do is text
insurance to 33789
text insurance to 33789
patty is in raleigh north carolina hi
patty welcome to the ramsay show
hello mr ramsay how are you doing today
better than i deserve what's up
so i have a what would they do question
for you
uh our family is on baby step number
seven uh we paid off our home
late last year excellent and and the
plan was to buy
an investment property this year uh but
as you know the
real estate market is crazy hot right
now and people are paying
thousands of dollars over asking so
we are wondering if we should continue
investing in mutual funds for now until
the market cools down
or should we jump onto the bandwagon now
because the prices are only going to go
up for the next few years
yeah i do not buy real estate unless i
buy it at a good deal
and a good deal means considerably less
than market value
period yeah i just don't there are no
good deals right now
well that's not quite true but it's
really close to true
it's very very difficult and i
impossible to find one
and the uh and so no i would not write a
check for more than an appraisal
to buy a piece of real estate as an
investment for sure
so what i would end up doing where i in
your shoes is i would just park that
money
and uh i parked mine in just an s p 500
fund
uh an index fund it's going to follow
the market exactly
whatever the stock market does is what
it's going to do and then when
i decide to buy a piece of real estate i
just use the money in that fund that's
my little real estate savings fund
yeah now uh uh and so
that what that does is it doesn't
prohibit you from continuing to look you
just
don't buy unless you found something and
we all know it's going to be
you know it's going to be very difficult
to find something right now it's not
like you're going to find something
every week
at a good deal it's very difficult so if
you want to just set yourself on the
sidelines
because tooth had got much work to find
a deal right now i don't blame you
that's fine
and when the market softens up a little
that's fine or if somebody just
you know put out a feeler with several
real estate agents look if you get
somebody's in trouble
and you run across something i can write
a check and we can close in 24 hours
if you find that somebody's in a pinch
and they need to get out
but i will not be doing that for
anything except for a bargain
okay and just you know put your couple
real estate agents on notice and they
can kind of be watching for you and if
they see something
you know a lot of them don't necessarily
they see deals they don't have the money
to buy
and so they got somebody like you in
their back pocket they can pick up the
phone and call you
um and that's a way to not be completely
sidelined
i mean you don't have to just declare
the market completely impossible you can
declare it very difficult
right and that's really what it is i'm
not out shopping for real estate right
now for two reasons one is the market's
too difficult it's not worth the effort
two is we're in the process of
developing the piece of ground that this
that ramsay's on and we're getting a
break ground on a conference center
that's 35 million dollars and that's
going to take all of my real estate
investment money
so i can't be out buying other property
right now uh
yeah these pieces of concrete i'm
sticking on this piece of land out here
are pretty serious
so um but that's that's you know
so i'm in other words we're developing
property but for business purposes as
well as real estate
investment purposes hayden is with us
hayden's in lynchburg
virginia no less hey hayden how are you
good dave how are you doing great how
can ken and i help
so i'm 15 years old and you know
it's about time for me to start
considering you know what i can do with
my life
and i feel like i'm being called into
ministry
but i don't want to end up going to
school and having a bunch of college
debt
and you know not being able to afford to
live comfortably
um so i'm wondering if i should maybe go
into like a trade
um i'm good at working with my hands so
go into a trade save
the money and then go to school for
ministry after i have the money saved up
yeah certainly not a bad plan hayden but
at 15
i'm just curious how much time you spent
with people that are in ministry
have you talked to other men that are in
ministry in different ministry positions
um not really um of course i'm very
involved in church um i love going um
but i haven't really spent a lot of time
speaking to anybody
in ministry good let me ask you this do
you have a vision right now
and how clear is it what does that
ministry position look like i know
you're only 15. but fast forward
10 years what are you doing
well i would like to you know be out of
college and be
you know either associate pastor or
youth pastor at a as a
church sure so here's what i want you to
do you're only 15
and that's great that you have a real uh
sense of
uh of calling or at least a tugging
towards ministry
so what you want to do is you want to if
you go to church and i'm assuming you do
you want wanna
you wanna spend some time with coffee
with your youth pastor
uh have him connect you with other
pastors in the area and really
get an understanding of what all is
involved day to day and i think
one of two things is gonna happen as you
spend more time really talking about
what does a life and ministry look like
and you can ask
questions if they'll tell you about what
a salary range looks like
your heart is going to either say yes or
no to that but if you
are feeling this tug towards ministering
the only thing that's concerning you
is money then that's something that
you're going to have to really look at
because i'm just going to tell you
moving into ministry for money that's
never going to satisfy you and you're 15
and that's okay so i love that you're
thinking about it but that's what i want
you to do
really see what your heart's telling you
when you get really clear
on what a full-time ministry position
consists of and i'm talking ask these
pastors
what's your worst day like what's the
hardest part about ministry
what do you love the most about ministry
you need to know that now let me address
your money question
i absolutely have no problem if you can
make good money in the trades
and you come out of high school and i'd
start looking for some jobs in the
summer working for the trades
they need help like crazy and a sharp 15
year old who can do the job can make
good money
but i love that plan of going in and
using your talent in the trades
to make some really good money to pay
for college and seminary
i absolutely love that plan because you
can
cash flow your way through it yeah i
already have about 3 500 in an
investment account in mutual funds
so you know i'm trying to build that up
you know hopefully over the summer
like he said i i have some connections
to people who own their own construction
company
so maybe getting out there throwing a
bunch of money into that uh mutual funds
and hopefully building that up
yeah absolutely and again i'm fine with
the gap year between
the next couple years and a gap year how
much money can you make in the trades
you can make
really really good money i love that
anthony o'neill wrote a book called debt
free degree
and and you can actually do this you
don't have to go into debt at all so
don't assume at 15
well i don't want to go into debt great
but make that a conviction statement not
a
well i really don't want to have to you
do not have to go into debt
to go to school to go into ministry i do
not know what the percentage
of youth pastors in america that have
uh theological degrees seminary degrees
are but
i would guess it to be well below 50
percent that's correct
yeah four year degree that would i would
guess
um again that would depend depend on
your denominational
background and which area which type
kind of church you want to go into and
so forth and
how you're serving and um you know so
there's nothing to say
and by the way um the average church
size in america is
85 and the typical pastor in america is
bi-vocational meaning they have a trade
job
and they're ministering on the weekends
so you can
actually move in that direction too um
if you wanted to as a possible way
to flesh this out and over time you're
going to be able to make the determine
whether this is a call to ministry
or just you are in love with jesus and
you want to help people meet him
by the way they can be the same thing
and they can be done in a whole lot of
different
settings so um whether it's a call to
full-time vocational ministry
may or may not be there you'll see as
you get along
i'm glad that you're being called that
way this
is the ramsay show
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
screen live on the show make sure you
visit thermsyshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car
rental studio this is the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation
about your life and your money i'm john
deloney joined here by
best-selling author brilliant
and often kind i was about to say
co-worker rachel cruz how are you
guys doing great john good to be back
with you and also with you thank you
very much
and we've got a pack studio house it's
good to see everybody here in nashville
and yeah dear franklin how are we doing
i think they're probably waiting on the
big guy
and they get
i appreciate you not calling me the big
guy i went jogging this morning so i
will
never i didn't mean it i know what you
meant rachel i'm trying i'm trying
jeez louise but you're doing well yeah
doing great i'm excited about tomorrow
night
yes so let's talk about it i know we
have an event our money and marriage
events
we did one on valentine's night
this year which was the biggest event in
ramsey history uh on the live stream and
the one that
they people stayed the longest amount of
any live stream i was like because we're
fun
i think they were thinking this is a
train wreck that just keeps happening
and we want to watch all of it to the
last flame burns out
maybe so maybe so but we're trying it
again yes this friday night so if you
don't have plans it's thirty dollars you
can go to ramseysolutions.com
marriage to get more information but
it's gonna start at 7 30
east central time central yes and it's
all new stuff
yeah we changed all the content and
we're talking about money we're talking
here's the thing we started looking at
pain points and listening to what our
callers on our show is talking about
so we're going to talk about stuff we
haven't talked about before like what
your money means we're going to talk
about sex we're talking about
intimacy we talk about stuff that's
affecting real couples in real time
right now that's right
because we you know this and we say it
all the time but it's just true
you know so many money problems we
talked to with couples like we can't
budget together i don't want to combine
our accounts like
you hear these problems and it's never
that problem right
it's usually deeper issues going on so
we're gonna kind of go three layers deep
pull back some of the layers and get
into get into the good stuff yeah and
we're gonna have some fun fun fun yeah
that's great
special guest we're gonna have all kind
of cool stuff so ramsay solutions.com
marriage gentlemen if you are listening
to this
this is a 30 way to win 30 bucks you can
say honey i love you and we're not going
to watch
netflix we're going to work on our
marriage and you win
right 30 bucks man 15 bucks a piece
that's cheaper than a movie right i
don't know how much a movie costs
i haven't been to a movie and i do miss
movies do you
kind of yeah going to a theater the
whole experience time
my daughter went for the first time the
other day and that's gonna be fun though
yes i'm excited
all right let's go to james in illinois
james what's going on man
how are you guys remarkable brother how
are you
i'm good i'm good so what's up man how
can we help
so me and my fiance will be getting
married this year
and she will be starting graduate school
for counseling
and i was just curious how or what your
guys's advice would be
for supporting someone while they're in
graduate school
mentally emotionally but also still
prioritizing a new marriage
it's a great great question when do you
get when do you guys get married
in may and may so
she'll be starting graduate school in
august
okay so yeah so you'll have about six
months or so this is exciting i was
trying to think i was like what's the
month today yeah it's july
rachel's a great counter yes hey this is
what's gonna be so fun for y'all
as you're working through your
engagement she's going to be taking
marriage and family therapy courses and
you are going to be her
guinea pig number one so here's
me and my wife did this um what do you
do for a living man
i'm a pe teacher a pe teacher very cool
are you going back to grad school this
year are you just gonna teach
have fun and look forward to your new
marriage
uh the second one okay so
um i was lucky rachel and james i was
lucky when
when um i was doing grad school my wife
was doing grad school and so
it does take a lot of evening times
especially in counseling classes are
usually in the evenings from 6 to 9 p.m
then you got to write papers then you
got to read
and so what i strongly recommend you all
do is
make a budget for your time talk about
what the week looks like
what assignments are coming up what
reading things are going to look like
and make sure that when y'all that y'all
do set up time for each other
and you've got to be really clear and
she should know this but she's not going
to
um you got to be really clear the
counseling stuff that she's learning
stays at school it does not come home
you are not a guinea pig you are not her
first and only client you are her fiance
soon to be her
um husband and so make sure you guys set
up some time for one another
and you are going to have to work really
hard to a not get your feelings hurt
because this is a short term this is a
couple of years that she's investing
into
both of y'all's future but you're going
to feel neglected that's just part of
this you're going to say
well can't you go hang out you got to
read another dumb book and blow up go to
club
you're going to have to find some
hobbies you're going to have to do some
stuff that's going to keep you busy and
occupied
maybe i don't know help around the house
um maybe
do pick up more than quote unquote your
share of the domestic stuff but y'all
got to make sure you're you're doing
this together
you're going to have to find some stuff
that are going to keep you busy and keep
your heart plugged in
and then be really intentional about
setting up time to
uh be with be with each other right
that's just y'all's time
yeah i mean i think i think setting the
expectation of time is just huge know
her schedule
and just know okay this is this is you
know i feel like that when things go
unchecked
there are people and especially in a
relationship you have expectations
but they're not talked about they're not
communicating you don't see it on paper
right
you miss each other so as long as you
know the schedule what's going on and
you know it's a commitment on the front
end and so i think that that's great and
then
yeah i think what you said about leaving
the school stuff at school like my
husband and i we work
in the same place and so it's in our my
family right so like it's so easy
when you get together to talk business
or to talk work and
you know just like parents like we can
talk about our kids all the time right
so like i think there's certain subjects
you have to be intentional with
to say you know we're actually gonna
have other conversation besides the
obvious
subjects and for you guys the obvious
subject will probably be her
her schoolwork right and considering it
as in counseling to be like oh okay but
tell me this though
she could learn a lot of useful things
oh it would be it'd be great
wouldn't it though to be like oh my gosh
okay i'm learning this and this and
that's interesting
and that's ah so james if she comes home
and says hey i learned these five new
questions let's ask these
of each other that's fantastic okay when
she comes home and says
i think you have borderline personality
disorder then next week she's gonna come
home and say
i'm pretty sure you're schizophrenic and
then the next week it's going to be
right so that's when you've got to have
some language for one another and i
think this is for
every couple not just somebody who's um
marrying somebody who's getting a degree
in counseling but specifically in
counseling
my wife does a lot of coaching
professional women especially yep i for
years have spent time behind closed
doors to folks
and i come home she can feel it on me
but she also knows
there's ethical issues i can't tell her
what i talked about with somebody right
and
i don't ask her who her clients are so
james you all
need to come up with a language that
said that you've got permission to tell
her
hey you look like you got some heavy
stuff on your heart without you prying
for details
right and i think that's you and winston
right if you go home every day rachel
and you
unload on on winston every person in the
office who is mean to you today or who
you thought was me nobody's mean to
rachel by the way
she always is feeling it right but but
winston if he's a good husband he's
going to come up here tomorrow
ready to just yeah get ready and so
there's got to be some sort of
he had a hard day yeah he knows not to
ask you're not going to divulge but you
can just be with each other in those
totally hard moments right i think it's
great hey so if you want to um we're
going to talk marriage today triple
eight eight two five five two two five
talk about relationships getting married
all of that stuff
i'm john deloney joined by rachel cruz
and we are looking forward to seeing you
today
and tomorrow night for the event right
here on the ramsay show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsey show i'm john deloney
joined by best-selling author rachel
cruz and we're taking your calls on life
and money and today we're specifically
focusing on your marriage but we'll take
any of your calls triple eight eight two
five
five two two five and tomorrow night
live stream event we're gonna be in your
living rooms me and rachel cruz money
and marriage event all new stuff it's
gonna be a blast
go to ramseysolutions.com marriage to
learn more
join us it's going to be a hoot all
right let's go to what does that even
mean
i don't know really john those are out
of all the words you could use
to describe our great money and marriage
it's going to be neat kids that's what
you decided on
it's going to be an event for 75 and up
uh it's going to be exciting it's going
to be a hoot
what an idiot hunky dory and hoot
dory that all kind of goes together for
me oh my god
my grandmother's shaking her head now
all right let's go to brandon out in
phoenix what's up brother brandon how
are we doing
good how are you guys doing outstanding
what's up man how can we help
um so i've been having problems with
i'm more of a spender i'm sorry i'm more
of a saver
and paying off debt whereas my wife is
more of a spender as soon as again comes
in an account
goes away if i try to pay off debt it
builds back up
because she just she just spends the
money that i
already pay off now
i'm just trying to figure out how can i
fight this um to keep that from
happening
uh it's a great question brandon um i'll
just say a couple things from what you
just
said um just to point out it
felt like a lot of she me
separate pages and then your last
question even what can i do
how can i fight this how can i fight my
wife no i know what you mean brenda i
know what you mean
but your language it says a lot you're
in a you're in a tough spot you're
frustrated
she's probably frustrated you guys are
on totally separate pages
so the goal here obviously is to become
one
on this so my question would be number
one what does she say to you in response
to spending does she just do it and
there's no communication
are you guys fighting about it talking
about it like like what else is going on
um so we do talk about it but it's more
of after the fact when she spends i look
at the account and see that she spent
we tried talking about saving and
everything we even looked at the dave
ramsey program and
she didn't seem too interested in it um
she knows that we are in debt a little
bit and
i've already had to pull a loan out of
my retirement to help pay for that
to pay off the credit card loan but even
though we paid
one section of it off she just keeps
adding on to it does she give you a
reason why
is it stuff that is it like groceries or
is she just like frivolously spending
just for loosely spending um groceries i
would get i completely understand that
it's uh it's just like clothes makeup uh
stuff like that what else are you not on
the same page
there's something else going on here
um that's pretty much it to be honest
um how long have you been married we've
been married four and a half years and
we've been together for eight i'm having
a hard time buying that everything y'all
are in sync together you're making
future plans you're all on the same page
except that when you say hey i'm really
scared about our debt and i'm really
scared about our future trajectory she's
like i hear you
but check out these shoes that can't
that can't be
that way um i mean the only other thing
i can think of it's not between me and
her but
um about a year ago she was diagnosed
with postpartum depression and anxiety
okay um she thinks that has something to
do with it
i don't know okay um she does see a
counselor and everything for that
do you have you ever gone with her
um i did in the beginning because her
counselor wanted me there
now i go to my own counselor for other
problems that i had with work but um it
kind of trickles into
personal life as well yeah it doesn't
trickle in it's the same river and
i'll just echo what rachel said just
listening to your language
you have a really remarkable roommate
but you'll see your own counselors you
do your own budgets you have your own
dreams for your own individual futures
and you have not
built a life together
and so i get that if man
um i've sat with a number of women who
experience postpartum that feel
completely alone and their husbands
don't have the tools
or the insights or even the desire to
reach across
it's a mess um what you've got to do
is go first brandon and be vulnerable
and say i'm worried about our marriage
i love you and i'm not doing a good job
of connecting
we're i'm not doing a good job of
getting on our same page
and so i want us to go see somebody
together so that we can learn some new
tools this isn't an accusation this
isn't you bought something again unbelie
this is you coming and being vulnerable
and saying hey i want to learn some new
skills
because i'm not doing a good job of
communicating and i'm not doing a good
job of creating an us
and i want to learn how to do that
better so would you join me in that and
it sounds like you're both open to
therapy
to both open and see somebody but you're
there now yeah and and i mean and
brandon
when it comes to that kind of spending i
guess it's not like yeah she went
five fifty dollars over the food budget
right and you're some like
i mean it's it's an obvious uh coping
mechanism for her
it feels good to go and get this stuff
right so she may even
logically know the numbers and no we
don't have the money but in that moment
it's like she just
needs that dopamine she needs something
to put a band-aid on the pain that's
going on in her so i do want you to have
a lot of grace
and a lot of empathy sympathy just to be
able to to
understand why she's doing it it's not
in spite of you it's probably out of her
own hurt and pain
but that's still on her she has to know
how to control that
and to take that coping mechanism out
because that stuff is not
going to heal right that stuff does not
heal well you heal through connection
right
right that's right that's right and man
don't do something dumb
like take out a loan against your 401k
and then blame her for it
i'm going to do this because because now
you're doing something stupid yourself
and you're going to make her the enemy
and go ahead i'm sorry i was going to
say two brandon and when you elevate
these kind of conversations
versus like how do i fight against this
how do i get in the nitty-gritty
if you guys above it and just like when
you see marriages i want to i want you
to win
at you know my you know looking at her i
want you to win and her to be able to
look at you and say i want you to win
like how do we
how do we win together what are the
things we're shooting for and to set a
goal you guys have a goal for the next
three years maybe it's a trip you plan
maybe it's
redoing a room in your house like i
don't care what it is like have
something that you guys are working
towards
together i mean if you obviously you
guys have debt so paying off debt would
be a huge goal
but have something together because
there's a level of unity that's created
in marriage when you say hey we're gonna
we're gonna be one
in this subject and it's hard it may
cause conflict
there's a lot of you know it rubs
against what i want what you want but
man we're going to push through
and become that team like when you can
elevate that conversation versus just
the tactical as well brandon
that that hopefully will get bring some
encouragement and exciting stuff right
because
it's all great stuff good stuff like we
want to be better
we want to go towards awesome not okay
go to
what was the word i used earlier um we
want to go towards a hoot right we want
to go towards awesome
not always spend our time running away
from fire yes exactly
exactly so rachel you you've been doing
this a lot longer i have
it feels like in the last year and a
half when i've been sitting in this room
it's when a husband or a wife goes to
their spouse and says
hey i want us to do dave's thing yeah
it's not dave's thing like dave created
a path and identified a plan but it has
to be our thing
that we are doing for us and for our
legacy and for our future and for our
communities etcetera right yeah and
what's hard too is the one and
i'm not putting this on you brandon but
usually the one that wants to go gung-ho
is more the legalistic one naturally
usually
the one that's a saver like i mean
they're more
excited about this naturally versus the
one you know his wife's like i'm gonna
go buy
clothes and shoes and makeup like i want
to go have fun and so that
legalistic person can come in and suck
the life out of that spouse that's more
of a free spirit right so
that dynamic is interesting so what if
brandon underneath illegalism
said hey we just had a new baby and i'm
looking at our finances
that's right do it for the baby and i'm
scared yes yes
i know a number of wives that would love
to hear the words from their husband
hey i'm scared and i don't know how to
say this and my default setting is to
pull out a spreadsheet and try to save
us that way
and your default setting is just to
ignore it but
i'm nervous about tomorrow looks like
what if we what if we
got on a plan together and by the way
this guy named dave created a plan for
us to use in our home right
yep and now you're talking about legacy
change but brandon that's a lot easier
than to walk alongside then well look
what you made me do
right that's right do it together build
a future together
triple eight eight two five five two two
five give us a shout right here on the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we are back on the ramsay show i'm john
delony joined here by best selling
author and good friend rachel cruz and
we have
two rock stars on the debt
free stage lee and jessica how in the
world are we doing
good awesome awesome so i'm assuming
that if you're on the debt-free stage
you've got a great announcement to make
you're debt-free
amazing incredible job so where do you
live nebraska
nebraska and how much have you paid off
uh we paid off 325
000 whoa yeah did you pay your house
off no no that doesn't include the
mortgage no no we're in an apartment
right now
so 325 000.
what was the debt student loans mostly
student loans
what's your degrees uh uh the doctorate
in physical therapy okay and a doctorate
in occupational therapy
uh two doctors doctor and doctor
how long did this take you a little a
little under nine years
a little under nine years and what was
your range of income during this time
uh we started out at about 55 000
and uh between the two of us now we're
at about 150.
wow y'all 150 k and you kept at it for
nine years can i
say the fact you guys are in an
apartment with multiple
children two five half five
how is that when did you do that did you
sell the house in order to put towards
the we've never been in the house
okay okay we we started um with
financial peace early
um in our marriage we just been
following financial peace and dave
probably for about 13 years um got
through grad school
and then started on the debt snowball so
all right so what y'all did the math
you all got out of school with 325 000
right yeah
at some point you looked at each other
and said we just got to start on this
thing and this is what the next
decade of our life is going to look like
how did y'all come to that conclusion
who had this conversation how
did this thing go man well jessica kind
of came to me and said
hey at church they're doing this
financial thing and i said
i'm good i i i've never bounced a check
um you know we'd had a couple
discussions
just completely opposite backgrounds
my my perception of being good with
money
was keeping the checkbook in the black
and
you know oh you know rent's coming due
and i just bought a flat screen tv so
what do
you know like i gotta go earn some money
and
i think at one point um jess had
spent like two hundred dollars on five
coffees because they overdraft so i mean
just you know the opposite normal
different normal
opposite normal like that yeah financial
spectrum and so
um you know so i asked him to
do financial peace with me and he was
kind of hesitant at first he didn't want
to he thought he was he's good with
money he's good you're
you're the one that's terrible right so
you need it
um so i was so thankful because um that
just set us up as a really good
um to start our marriage and if we
wouldn't have done that oh my goodness i
feel like we would have had so many
more fights of money and just stress of
money and we were able to be on the same
page of it and it was awesome
so we live in a culture now where nine
minutes of struggle is is annoying right
sitting having to wait through a traffic
light for nine minutes is hard
right nine days to get a call back from
the dentist i feel like oh they hate me
y'all looked at the math here and said
we're two doctors
we help people's healing for a living
and we got
nine years ahead of us in an apartment
and by the way we have 117 children
right at some point you had to say hey
we're in this together
how did y'all come to this like this is
a hard conversation i have hard
conversations for a living
this one's hard yeah it's it's multiple
conversations throughout the years um i
mean
there were there were years where it was
gazelle and tents and the kids were
asking which one was getting sold next
because we were selling so much stuff
um after our daughter was born we
we cleaned house we we had a garage sale
we sold
anything that wasn't you know stapled to
the walls
you know and um we've gone through
financial peace a couple times
just to kind of stay stay motivated and
say like are we missing something
um how do we you know it's
it's sacrifice it is it's um taking
lumps on some money and putting it
towards
the big goal and knowing that
in the long run it's going to give us
more time
with the people and our kids absolutely
that we want to spend okay so how did it
feel
like when you guys made that final
payment after nine years
amazing what did it feel like yeah it's
like what do you want to do like
where should we go where you know and um
you know obviously we say tennessee so
nashville yeah who's your biggest
cheerleaders who walked alongside you
nobody does this kind of journey for a
decade by themselves
i everybody thought we were crazy though
like they are like why are you doing
this why don't you get a house why don't
you
like it's completely different so my
guess is this is more than that i bet
people
didn't just say hey why don't you get a
house i bet they said hey what kind of
life are you providing for these kids
like
yeah this is the point where they're
coming after you yeah yeah as a parent
yeah right yeah yeah right i mean we had
a we had a van that was rusting out and
it was down by the river
yeah we're gonna keep going it was the
debt snowball van and
you know our in a week things
drastically changed for us you know we
we we got the money that we were waiting
on to pay off the debt
and it freed up money to buy a new van
and so like
you know for those people that are in it
just keep
trudging along just keep going find that
cheerleader
it was pastors it was it was parents it
was
a small group you know it was friends
you know like hey i'm really having a
struggle i really
i really feel like i need a new car
because i've i've never owned any car
from the 2000s personally
it's just it's tough and you need that
person to say like
what's your end goal and not what's
going to feel
good right now yeah and not so good
let's get those let's get those
five beautiful kids up here what are
their names and ages
uh we have abram who's 10 um israel
is eight ada will be seven here in july
josiah is five and boaz is ten months oh
my goodness
i'm trying not to come out of this chair
because this is a sit-down show
but i'm looking at these five beautiful
kids
and i don't want you to miss this moment
that you have changed the trajectory of
their
life yes it is different because two
parents
said i'm gonna suck it up for a decade
in an apartment and young kids i want
you to know your parents
are rock stars and y'all missed out on
disneyland you missed out on some crazy
stuff and now the floodgates are about
to open
because mom and had a hard conversation
with dad and they did this together
so so so proud of you
lee and jessica from omaha nebraska
paid off 325 000
in nine years changing the lives of
all 800 you've got five kids all five
kids
and yours you are debt free let's do
count it down on your debt-free scream
it's ready that's ready ready on three
three two one
oh my gosh man
talk about a marathon talk
about america nine years nine years
i look at her as a mom and i'm like oh
that was three presidents ago
three presidents to go yes i mean
that's hot that is hard you guys i mean
we get we get we say
your debt turnaround is 18 to 24 months
on average on here so we get stories all
over the place all income levels all
debt levels yes but that right there
like
it's commitment that's that's remarkable
absolutely and you've got
community members 325 000 i know
and they say we support you but somebody
took them out to
for coffee and said hey what are you
doing just get a house for crying out
loud
hey we love you but this video enjoy the
enjoy the moment the van's gotta go
you're a doctor now
right you are a doctor you're a doctor
do you feel like connected you know
you're a doctor too sort of you know
yeah there are what i like to call real
doctors where they actually
they help people and they don't john's a
doctor they don't just run their mouth
on the radio
you'll see actual clients and patients
no they're i'm
amazing you guys incredible the beauty
of this job
is coming here every day and thinking
that my job is to inspire other people
and then i see
you guys and i go home a better dad
and a better husband in a better
community member a better neighbor
because i get to be
in contact with you guys y'all are
heroes
i love it 325 000 sweet kids
right here on the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture is psalm 25 21 may
integrity and of brightness protect me
because my hope lord is in you andy
andrews says to become a great leader
don't focus on becoming a great leader
instead focus on becoming someone worth
following
that's good good i know all right
blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window covering you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run
every month you'll save even more use
promo code
ramsey to get the best deal rules and
restrictions
apply today's question comes from kate
in south carolina
my husband and i have been married three
years the house we live in is on his
mother's property she's overstepped
boundaries and this is called a lot
caused a lot of issues i want to move so
we have privacy in our own space i've
tried
to talk to my husband but he doesn't
want to move
after a big fight he agreed to look at
other homes
but refuses to sell the current house
which
we would need to to buy another house
i'm at a loss as to how to move forward
what are your thoughts
on the property i would want to know why
and again obviously
kate's not a caller right now but i'm
like i i want to know why does he want
to stay is it because it's a
co-dependency on his mom and his family
or is it because like the house is a
great deal and
the property is 800 acres and
they they're you know i mean like but i
bet it's not
i have it's a hard one
i have heard i haven't experienced this
but i've heard over the years
um a dynamic between mother-in-laws
and their daught their sons wives
yeah daughter-in-laws yeah that there is
a level of tension that often husbands
are completely oblivious to
they just waltz in and out of the world
like oh it's fine and their wife says
it's super not
fine but they got to be careful because
that's their mom and they want to
not offend their thin-skinned husband
but
this this is a this is a bigger red flag
than it looks
okay and so um kate this is one of those
moments that you all need to
get out of this house um and go
somewhere
and let your husband know that not i
want to have a conversation about our
house but i don't have a conversation
about what's the trajectory of our
relationship what's the trajectory of
our
of our future where are we headed here
yeah
where you're gonna live is part of that
but if you focus on the house the house
the house
the your mom your mom your mom if your
husband will try to fight a bunch of
little battles and you're both gonna end
up losing this
this relationship yeah and so i want you
to go somewhere and have a conversation
about hey where are we headed what are
we doing
and in that conversation kate can talk
about here are some real
tangible ways your mom makes me
uncomfortable here's how she's
overstepping boundaries
here's how you are making me feel
husband while you're picking your that
you're picking your mom over
for me i was gonna say that's yep and
here's the uncomfortable statement
that's not a popular statement but this
is a truthful statement kate
you're gonna have to at some point come
up with your or what statement
your or what moment right
because just nagging about this poking
at this
complaining about this um will lead you
to drown along with him you've got to
have a
hey i'm i'm telling you in three years
we got to be on this house in 24 months
we got to be out this house and then you
got to come up with an or what statement
and if you are not
i'm not going to ever leave him then
you're going to have to make peace is
where you live if that's where you want
to live that's you're going to live
it's or you're going to have to say i'm
going to have to make hard decisions
here if you don't honor me enough
to do this yes to look into it because
it is it's an example of
he's not honoring her in this situation
which means
where where could he not honor her and
others right that's right like it's that
level of trust
right and it often again i'm poking at
him
he may not know what a big deal this is
he may be he hearing this as i don't
sell the house i like her house and then
moving on about the day
right and doesn't understand the weight
that this is an existential issue for
his wife so
get out of the get out of the changing
environment change the conversation
about a legacy conversation about where
we go in conversation
and this is a part of it right it's good
all right let's go to tanner in
vancouver what's up tanner how are you
doing
hi how are you i'm great how about you
not cheaper so
me and my wife are fine and we're
stronger than ever but
um my my rights last night um
has an issue being around my my
mother alone
she my mom has went and turned around
and
i've never witnessed it but my mom has
went and talked to her
talk down to her um and i'm just i'm
trying to know
i'm trying to be faithful to my wife and
not or not people but loyal to my life
but i just i don't know where to go with
this
so we're just talking about that with
this blinds.com call
um when you say talk down to what what
did your wife tell you
how about that uh her name is katarina
okay what did katharine she came to you
last night and said and what'd she say
um well she didn't say anything i was
talking to her
because we're planning a trip out to
them
i i live on in vancouver and
my in-law or my my family lives out in
ontario
and i i left
ontario because i needed to make a
drastic move because my
my family and her have never gotten
along and we have
a 10 year old in the mix of it
so i'm trying to do what's right by my
my wife and
and i just i've never heard her
heard my mother say anything so i don't
and i'm not saying that my wife is
overreacting because
it's your wife stanner is your wife
lying to you
i don't i don't think so i i honestly
like she has no reason to lie
i don't care about any of that stuff is
your wife lying to you okay
no okay then i want you to sit down and
hear your wife let her be open to you
and then at some point you have a
responsibility to go to your mom
and say this stops now yeah because i
pick her over you and if
my if your mom's gonna act like a child
and your mom's gonna run your wife down
which is which by proxy is gonna run
down your 10 year old in the mix here
then your mom is self-selecting out of
your relationship
and i know that's a hard conversation
and it's an uncomfortable conversation
and it's a
conversation but this is one of those
hard-line moments right
it is and tanner i can even hear it in
your voice though he wants he wants to
do the right thing for his wife that's
right you know
like this wasn't like my wife you know
sometimes it's pinned the other way
where the wife's the bad one you know
situ in the situation
but you you know yeah you're in a
marriage and you're number one as your
wife
and and i feel that from you and i think
sitting down and having that boundary
conversation
it'll either clear it up and it'll stop
it or it's going to
cause more friction between you guys
well i think it clears up either way
right yeah yeah yeah tanner it's
important you don't go to war with your
mom and don't be disrespectful and don't
be ugly and don't
call her like you should that's not how
you do that you go visit your mom right
yes and you have this conversation in
person and say hey i love my wife and
she's who i chose and here's the deal
too i think some women can be passive
some women maybe also extend i don't
know we can be passive aggressive at
times so your mom
well she probably knows what she's doing
she may not even know the weights
that a flippant comment can make that
was very hurtful do you know what i mean
so to
i don't know but i know they've had a
rocky relationship you said they've
never really liked her so there's
probably gonna be a lot of stuff there
to unpack but
and this is a conversation that you have
respectfully and with dignity yeah
but this is a moment when you step up
for your family and for your
wife and your kid and you say um i'll go
talk to my mom
that's right all right let's take a one
last call let's go quick hey jess we're
up against the clocks let's get right to
the question what's going on
hey um so i am actually
dating a guy that is um
has a mom and we're talking about
marriage and he is saying that she will
not leave him any inheritance
if i don't sign a prenup and i was just
kind of wanting to get your thoughts on
that should i do it
um should i not how big is the
inheritance jess
i don't know to be 100 but i'm thinking
it's going to be more like
5 million spread out between his
brothers which is he has two brothers so
it's not like he's getting 20 million or
anything like that
no my thing's no with prenups my
always my rule of thumb is if there is a
large sum of money and there's something
like
voting stock within a family business i
mean if there's if there's a substantial
thing there
it's my one time where i'm like okay i
can understand it because it could
affect the rest of the family
in something else and it protects you
guys to have some bunch of your family
coming out of the woodwork to try to get
this fortune of this yes
but five million is great don't get me
wrong
five million seems like a lot of money
but it's great it's great but spread out
over the long haul i'm like
i mean that here's mine i don't like it
here's my concern jess
my concern here is i want your husband
going back to his mom and saying i'm
marrying this woman
i hope you'll be with us i don't like
your husband putting you in the position
hey mom said
right he needs to stand up for you if
this marriage is going to have any legs
on it whatsoever
hey thanks so much for joining us i want
to say thank kelly daniel and james
childs for running the boards and taking
the calls
rachel look forward to the money and
marriage event tomorrow night ramsay
solutions.com
marriage thank you for joining us be
kind to one another
this is the ramsay show
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
[Music]
thermzyshow.com
you